how long were you on the run six years
2007 everything happened
i caught two cases 107 108
and 07
it got kind of like dismissed but
without uh without prejudice so they
could bring it back right
it was really a weak case you know um
and
so i'm out you know um in oh eight i
caught another case
and i'm trying to like at this point i'm
trying to really like straighten up you
know what i'm saying
um actually in oh seven i was trying to
straighten up but it was like people
always say when you're making that kind
of money fast money like i'm a i'm gonna
get x amount and then get out it's
impossible you know what i'm saying i
mean yeah it's it's i'm sure it can
happen but it's really hard you know i
mean because it comes so fast you spin
it just as fast as you get it because
you know you can get it again yeah i
mean so
i was like [ __ ] i just got to keep
getting it and me fighting cases was
expensive
so i'm fighting cases ankle bracelet
still trapping you know what i'm saying
so
so 08
um caught another case they came and got
me um i had a bunch of guns at my house
and they brought the other case they
brought both cases back simultaneously
so they can get me
on felony release with weapons
so they try some slick [ __ ] pulled me
over in the middle of the street
it was so over the top i'm like all
right
shotguns and [ __ ]
um but
you know you go through the horseshoe
and you see the judge in 24 hours
and
she was like okay well
she's about to say the bond and this
[ __ ] woman on the side like actually
your honor he doesn't get a bond he's a
dangerous violent felon
these are serious crimes and he has all
of these like aks you know arizona
that's [ __ ] legal
right you don't say it but it just
looked bad yeah i don't even think it
was as legal back then though as it is
now because now it's like it was it was
super it was illegal but i think now
like
okay i know what it is it's a it's a law
that they got that saved my life called
uh stand your ground
no castle doctrine that's what it's
called they didn't have it when my [ __ ]
happened right because everything that
happened happened in my house i'm saying
uh you know so
but i was gone for so long by the time
they got me they had that law so if
you're on the run so you find out you're
essentially looking at serious time yeah
and you decide to just say [ __ ] it so i
tell you listen
i live life
life don't live me nothing happens to me
i do i you know and i'm not like saying
that in an egotistical way but i will
not allow somebody else to determine my
fate it's not happening and i didn't
feel like what they were trying to get
if they would have said like three years
five years i was like all right it's
about 15 to 20 years with no priors
that's crazy this ain't happening so you
mean tell me my kids are going to be
adults when i get out nah cool
and you know and people don't realize
uh with a violent offense
especially something of the nature of
mine you're in a way worse type of
facility it's gladiator school you know
what i'm saying so i'm like i know i'm
gonna be in there having to defend
myself catching more cases
so it just looked bleak you know what
i'm saying so i'm like now i'm good i'm
out of here so where'd you go
all over
all over the country did you end up even
i left the country for a minute um
and then like
me you know i stayed in communication
with my children and
i was like what the [ __ ] am i doing like
i i went on a run
so they won't separate me from my kids
but you're separating yourself i'm
separated from my kids so i came back
and um
you know i came back everybody figured
that i would have got caught by that you
know i'm saying
but i just don't move reckless i
calculate everything i study everything
about look i'm i was a valedictorian
student all my life you know what i'm
saying honor student all of that [ __ ]
so
i just did research
and seeing what i can do
what in cics whatever that shit's called
what do they track everything i looked
up everything
so i moved around so um when i got back
people did think that i was going to get
got caught by then and then some of my
friends they were like oh you could stay
with me you could come back i'm like
cool but when i came back it was a
surprise to them
so they was like i don't know and
rightfully so because this [ __ ] probably
wasn't 100 you know what i'm saying and
i'm bringing heat to them
so i didn't even it didn't bother me i'm
glad that no one allowed me to come stay
because it just put a certain type of
motivation
a little certain fire under me so i was
legit homeless for a minute bro and pete
this
i'm homeless right
i had like
i still had [ __ ] in the streets like
whips and [ __ ] like that other people
subleasing it and like [ __ ] was
talking [ __ ]
people that was nothing to me you know
what i'm saying i'm like what
so i was at a crossroad
i was you know full of fear full of
anger
full of confusion you know what i'm
saying when you got nothing
i have nothing right i don't it look
like i don't have a future
only i had was like violence and and
physical force and intimidation so i'm
gonna just
go to my my my default settings and i'm
knocking on doors
so i really was about to like go back to
arizona
you know what i'm saying and just ruin
my life
but
so when you you came back into the
country you you were in cali yeah okay
but i didn't because if you would have
went to arizona you would have just
started i would have been making your
rounds
for what i think nothing comes out of
that yeah
so what stopped me was my son you know
what i'm saying
his mother who's very smart
she made a weird call and was like hey
you want your son
here i am she don't even realize i'm
homeless
nobody knew that [ __ ] right i'm like
yeah i didn't know how i was gonna take
him or whatever but i figured that [ __ ]
out so that saved my life you know what
i mean and it was one day um i started
getting my [ __ ] together
i'm taking him to school then i have a
call i'm walking and
he little like six right
kindergarten maybe something like that
and or first grade so i'm walking to
school
um
when i when he comes out i'm there and
you know he can't see me because he's
little i could see him i see him looking
for me and i seen this one day bro his
eyes lit up when he seen me and just ran
just hugged onto my leg and then held my
hand tight and we walked home and i was
thinking like [ __ ]
like
this little perfect little human loves
me
i ain't got no car
i got no fly [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
and you know when i had all of that [ __ ]
i had nothing but fake love around me
you know what i mean
but this guy loves me you know what i'm
saying unconditionally unconditionally
so it made me love myself you know what
i mean
and
[ __ ] has been good ever since then bro
you know